thank you so much for um on your day off
for doing this interview with me i
really appreciate it as a fan of your
work i have a ton of things i want to
talk to you about which runs the gamut
of subjects
but i want to start with congrats on
raging fire being a huge box office
success in china and around the world um
congratulations thank you very much
if someone had never seen one of your
movies
what movie would you like them to start
with
i made so many movies i've been around
for ages i'm a dinosaur
especially
as an action with filmmakers you know
i
i act and i produce and i direction i
mean i i might my fingers they know they
don't know what i you know when they
think of founding yen is
you know the martial art actor uh
but in in my country i'm the i'm
who i am that
runs from
acting producing you know i i sometimes
i sing a little bit you know cameo in my
my friend's films and i do all kinds of
things i just love the art of
uh
the artistic
world
and very privileged and fortunate that
uh
what has been given to me in my last 40
years in the business i'm very uh
you know i'm i don't take anything for
granted i'm very lucky man
and i'm able to do this for business as
well as
having fun
utilizing
uh
a little bit of these artistic
value that i have to
for my movie so
yeah
so you don't you don't have a sp you
don't have a specific movie i don't have
a specific i mean if i tell people oh
watch it man and they think oh daniel is
it man
well i i think but then you can watch
chase and the dragon i don't know if
you've seen pages right dragon when i
played
a drug lord in
gangster mode
or if you watch flash point it's totally
opposite
different character it man is introvert
mad master kung fu
talk slow walk slow
he doesn't want to fight but he can
kick your butt right
but then flashpoint is more like
totally aggressive
fired up passionate
fights your head off you know
so
i don't know so if i guess you got to
see
at least
two movies
to see the cockpit at least two movies
so i say you know watch it man and watch
watch
kills on spo flash points you know watch
watch john wick
so seriously i mean so far i'm having
you know i have to take this opportunity
opportunity to my utmost appreciation
for both chad and keanu they're just
very lovely men you know they just
gentlemen
got a big heart
chian who got a wonderful
just got a good soul you know this is a
good man and chad
also a very good man
very knowledgeable
people think him is just a brilliant
action guy no he's not he understands
films he
you know he's a film librarian
he knows what's going on and and
and
yeah so i i'm just having the best time
best time working with them in this
movie
than any of my previous hollywood movies
so i wanted to
express my uh
my appreciation
well the other thing is um i've i've
been on the set of a john wick movie and
i think a lot of people
maybe they just don't realize that keanu
is really
really talented at doing action himself
and he really pushes himself
on a level that is
you know most people might not do i mean
you do but he is very talented oh he is
great he's just more than i it's
more than i was uh uh
expected he the guy is like does
everything himself
and he put in the hours he put in the
work and he can do it
he's no joke you know the guy's like my
i've gotta have that respect for him and
he
and he's just a cool guy to be around to
work with you know i've been on the set
a different movie where he just rode up
on his motorcycle yeah you know just
casual no big deal yeah yeah i love the
man he's a lovely you got a very gentle
lovely soul you know wonderful soul
completely jumping back into
you're in a unique position because i
would imagine a lot of people want to be
in business with you but is there a
project
throughout your career or now that
you've always been wanting to make and
for some reason you've never been able
to get the financing
i mean i think every actor or every
filmmakers have
a couple of these desirable projects in
their heart or desirable characters
right and i had quite a number of those
in my earlier days
but out of my
long
been around for ages career i've been in
the business for 40 years and made
making my 80s films right 80s film
i don't really have
i'm not that uh
how would i call it i mean i'm ambitious
as
as far as
i'm a perfectionist
if i decide to do
some
uh do a movie or a tackle role i try to
do the best i can right with no doubt i
don't know punches i you know i same
with canada you know i throw my body
into the to the freaking
[ __ ] if i need if i needed to you
know what i'm saying like i i need to i
gotta get the job done you know i don't
and i come i don't sleep i don't come
home 24 7. i'm constantly thinking about
what i did on what i'm going to do next
day right that's just my
always been always been my work ethics i
believe that's i have to tribute to
myself you know that's
but at the same time i don't really have
i'm not desirable as like some actors
like you know what oh i never played
that role before let me try to play that
role i don't have that kind of uh
that uh animosity or that that kind of
uh
advertise you know i don't have that you
know i'm not i'm not i'm not i don't i'm
not here to oh let me prove myself no
but
i am
very ambitious
in terms of i am
for the longest time i do want to
represent
as a chinese character as a chinese
actor
and
and represent
uh yeah my my culture my chinese culture
my roots which for the longest time i
believe
and
most people can't disagree with me
that uh
in the in the film industry but if
you're talking about the global you know
bigger than that it's not just film
industry but for the most part
most of the
majority of people in the world
doesn't truly understand the beauty of
my culture or the talents that
what i'll call uh
the the the beauty of our culture of the
what we can do for
the world and in this conversation
specifically for film we have a lot of
talented actors but unfortunately in a
lot of american films
asian actor
chinese actor in specific
never was given the opportunities the
other day i watched another film right i
scanned through a film while we're
talking about the subject about the
ghost uh the shell in the ghost uh the
ghost in the shell right
oh it goes in the shell
it's it's it's an asian i mean you know
come on you know
i don't understand but why is the
chinese actors are always uh stereotyped
when you cast a chinese actor he's
always got
his name gonna be chinese
i mean he gotta act a certain way that
in a western
culture would think oh this is how
presumably how chinese
act but
and but never really i'm never really
uh
really digging so dig deep inside of
what this person is about it's the
person not
whatever they look like right so for for
me as the chinese actor
i wanted to to break that i want to be
the person that to do something about it
you know that's why i constantly
discuss and try to to uh
to fight for a better uh understand like
in rogue one when they asked me to do
rogue one it wasn't like like that i
mean there's a lot of uh asian elements
and a lot of chinese elements in it you
know with my martial arts and the
costume and everything but it was
but it added humanity it had it added
humors it added a little bit of
different from what you expect and that
was a progression
of
of uh
what should what it should be uh
been seen for the longest time right so
with this role i i believe this is
another groundbreaking role for
for a uh
yeah
that's the per that's my personal
journey that's the kind of roles that i
want to play to represent
i've said repeatedly that hollywood can
do a much better job with representation
from around the world than they
currently do but i i feel as someone
looking at it from the outside that they
are making better inroads recently but
it's still not enough i look at for
example marvel having
getting ready to release you know
shanghai um which uh you know hopefully
that is something you know that's an
asian cast um are you planning is that
something that you're looking forward to
the shanghai
i
i mean there's a lot of uh i still i
think
to be famous right
they they try
but not hot enough
you talking about the mark
oh you mean hollywood oh
overall they try but
they're not catching up
like i'm going to give you example right
how many chinese restaurants
you find
in l.a
not in the chinese community but in the
other community how many
you have to think about it
and and those chinese restaurants
they're not really authentic
so but to them that's authentic so what
i'm trying to say is like what i'm
trying to say is like have they done the
research
with the culture
with the language
with how we dress
how we talk
i can give you my personal experience i
don't want to talk about i don't want to
put anybody down you know given you know
uh i'm not i'm not here to talk i'm not
here to criticize other people's uh
uh you know i appreciate what they've
done you know to putting they certainly
a milestone
uh
progression compared to say
10 20 years ago right but
my hat's
off
salute to that
but at the same time
there's still so much they could do from
my personal experience i did a film a
couple a couple films i'm not going to
talk about which film where the director
would actually don't even understand how
to hold a chopstick but he's directing a
chinese uh you know you know it's like
this little crazy things you know the
way just
i'm not really respecting
the important of these details these
details
is how you progress
and it should progress that way right so
yeah
and i
before i retire i would like to make a
few of those those films to to really uh
to express my uh
my my thinking
well it's interesting because you
directed earlier in your career and
obviously you action direct now and you
you know that that's a whole different
chapter but you actually directed uh a
few movies so i am wondering is that
something that you do you think with
your
um with who you are and your name that
may be directing something in the future
which is a melting pot of china and
hollywood in a way that maybe you're
uniquely suited to merge these two
entities well i wouldn't i wouldn't say
specifically directing the whole films
you know i've directed completely
back in 19 mid 90s i didn't directed
field films actually i never stopped
directing and many of the films that i
myself involved and many of the chinese
film where i produce i i basically just
a lot of those stuff were directed by me
but i wouldn't want to
i want to focus on you can only do so
much right i
think directing a complete movie would
kill me you know would age me another 10
years right so
but i i definitely my
i'm very hands-on person
whichever position that i'm in in the in
the film
whether i'm producing or just if you see
the title of be
acting or
like just acting only right without
other titles on
but i'm always known to very passionate
about
the subjects and the materials and
i would constantly
uh
i'm not gonna lose that right
before i retire you know every movie
that i ongoing i'm going to try to push
what i feel is correct or appropriate or
you know what makes a better material
makes a better representation i always
voice out you know so
yeah
but as far as directing the entire field
probably not
got it i've heard that from a number of
people um i am a huge fan of jackie chan
i know you obviously respect and love
jackie chan uh i am curious do you have
a favorite jackie chan movie and a
favorite jackie chan stunt
well
of course his classic was way back uh uh
with my mentor you more pain when he one
thing discovered me right and it's very
very classic like snake in the evil
shadows and drunken
uh master
uh that's where
i personally feel was jackie's prime
prime right but later on he also came up
with police story
and projects they were
those crazy stunts you know that really
revolutionized and put his stamps on the
world as wow you got the hong kong film
action filmmakers that's how we do films
you know the way
i mean think about it not we were crazy
and dare crazy and and
and innovative but at the same time
we were wildly unorganized basically we
a lot of these choreographies were
improvised on the set and decided to to
do it on the set you know and and it
became
kind of a part of history
no matter how much praise jackie gets
it's never enough for what he's done
for movie making
absolutely i mean he's he's the he's
he's a big brother you know he's done
and he's still very active you know a
very active producing and he
always uh
falls back on his roots you know
i you touched on rogue one for a second
and i just want to go back to it when
you think back on the making of the
movie what's like the first thing you
think about did it mean a lot to you to
be part of star wars um in the beginning
though i didn't know how uh significant
uh how influential show
i mean i of course i know star wars big
as
for you know i didn't follow star wars i
didn't watch every episode so when they
came in and called on me
uh
i wasn't sure that i was gonna i was i
got offers for other movies at the time
and i wasn't sure because i didn't want
to leave my family for
that long
and it ended up really long plus the
reshoot ended up like taking like nine
months eight nine months out of my life
in london right
but i didn't know what to expect i saw
the materials and
and and i needed to
make some addressment before i say yes
and and
lucasfilm uh disney and
and
the director were
we're very very gracious and he allowed
me to make some
changes to
satisfy my
certain
the terms you know okay i'll do this
role this
you're gonna let me do this
and it turns out and then it became
so popular
and everybody i didn't know what to
expect you know
a lot of these lines were improvised
you know i'm a chinese i'm a hong kong
filmmaker
from the old days where we improvised a
lot so
i mean i wasn't improvising fully but i
try to push my limit you know i try to
see what i can do and one day i put
price one two lines and so i thought oh
this that was funny and then they liked
it and put in the
you know the one when they put the bag
over me and i said hey you know you know
something like i'm fine i'm blind
just
things like little things like that you
know
but yeah i mean i'm glad it did it
became
well
my my kids loved it
i i also um i also really enjoy that
movie and considering the reshoots it
went through it's still good considering
how much you know
that movie just went through a lot
you know sometimes the audience doesn't
understand
uh most audience doesn't understand when
they just you know pay their tickets and
they go see a watch and feel it's so
easy to sit back and say you know this
is a great movie okay great all this is
shitty movies but they don't understand
what happened throughout the process you
know it takes so much
so many people to run so many decisions
on a daily basis every little details so
at the end of the day
you might have the best script or the
best idea
and the other day it might be crap or
the other way you might have a loosely
like everybody is insecure about what's
going to happen you know we don't have a
script we don't have this we don't have
that you know some of these
most classic films were made that way
some of the most not just chinese films
a lot of these chinese film were made
that way it was made out of
last minute decision of oh let's do this
movie put these actors together put in
the room no script what are we going to
do what we're going to say
and
next thing
now you have these classes i think some
of the american movies were kind of put
together that way i'm not suggesting
that's the best way to do it you know of
course we need a plan and organization
you know especially
the the industry is not as
it's not as
it's not as great as as
the prime days right so everybody got to
watch their budget and stuff like that
right but i think
just
we need to find balance and understand
families ultimately it's a business but
at the same time it needs to be
artistically
uh
you got to have that just an artistic uh
kind of space
for us to to expand to do our thing you
know and not restrict us like okay
you're gonna shoot five shots here
you're gonna finish two sets uh you
can't you gotta
allow the the artist to be too bit of uh
the freedom there you know
yeah it's interesting because i a lot of
people don't realize
that
movies are ultimately are their artwork
but they're also designed to make money
so the it's such a tricky balance
because you know you want you have to
return the investment of you know but
you also want to make something that no
one's seen before that entertainment
yeah it's a very tricky thing very very
tricky is this it's an is
knowledge is an art form that
even the most experienced maestro
filmmakers cannot win every single time
i mean i mean who can say that every one
of their films are successful film and
make money none of them the greatest the
biggest director biggest actor in the
world have some failed films right that
didn't work right so
yeah
i know you're a fan of ciao young fat i
am also a fan i constantly debate which
is my favorite between the killer and
hard-boiled do you have a favorite
between the killer and hard-boiled or
are they both equal
i think for i call them brother fat like
big brother fat
john [ __ ] i think my favorite is true if
it's not not killer the killer is a
stylistic film it's destruct the way
it's that character is cool
[Music]
it's written
that way it's given to that but i i i
was better i was more a lot more
impressed by better tomorrow well by the
way he wasn't written as the lead
if you didn't know the backstory the
back story was that he wasn't even
his role was small and it was not given
to him it was it was written for another
actor
but when he came to work
he just came to work and be who he was
and
it was this low point of his career
and sometimes when a person
is
when you're down
that raging fires in you right you fight
so he was there and he came and he was
so impressive that trump was started
writing expanding his role and he became
he stole the world history moving and
that's how he became
huge right from that field
so
from that film he did a couple other uh
other film
uh
non-action but more of a romantic uh
kind of role right and i thought it was
very impressive
but
killer is more stylistic especially
during that time you know between uh
during the the period you know it broke
grounds hard boil was just
people never seen john fuss work his
previous film
you just look at hot brows like wow
that's great but when you look at
better tomorrow or
some of his other work
they were even more impressive
i think the killer and hard-boiled have
a special place in my heart because
those were i think the first two films i
saw of his and john woo
and i just was like
i was like oh my god this is just
melting my brain this is unbelievable
you know so i think you know i saw that
at a young age and uh anyway that's so
jumping into why i actually get to talk
to you which is raging fire um before we
go any further in this movie i sort of
want to just touch on you know benny
chan and how he passed uh you know
making this film can you sort of talk
about um what he meant to you and
you know what he contributed to
filmmaking um in asia
i know benny
from
20 something years ago we collaborated
in a two tv series
uh
at the time was for a tv station called
atv which is the underdog
uh
and we broke grounds it became very
classic tv series at the time and all
the high ratings but then after since
then we never worked together he went on
to do other films director jackie and i
went on to do my films
but we always always cross path in
common studios where i edit my films and
yeah it's films and we always talk about
what we're gonna do next and when are we
gonna do next right
just chilly chat chat you know
and then uh a few years ago
uh he called me up and he said he just
saw chase in the dragon where i played
that drug lord guy right and he really
loved my falsehood it was so great that
you know when are we gonna do this
together
and then uh he came up with this
passionate
storyline concept
and originally we weren't going to do
agent 5 we're going to do this movie in
mexico
and him and some of my assistants my
stunt team went with him and his team
for location scouting he's we spent a
lot of pre-production money in mexico
and then he came back and he got a call
from the film company saying that uh
they want to
put up put that project on hold because
the movie costs a lot more so betty was
really down for a week or two and and i
was i actually was the one that
encouraged him i said you know
this is what you do best you do local
car movies
this is what you do you know benny chan
uh
one of the film that he did earlier is
called uh is it
something
anyway you gotta dig up the english
title right
and and i said you know you could do a
low budget and story can be
you know huh so he came out the
storyline within uh
within a week or two you know he called
me hey this is what we do
send and we
of course throughout the process we kept
changing back and forth
so
can turn back and forth with the story
uh of the cast and how we're gonna shoot
this and we both
were very
we had
we were both very um
fired up we wanted to
kind of revise
revive the
the hong kong action
especially this type of film
which is like you talked about the
killer you talked about the hot boy we
wanted to but we haven't seen this kind
of
strong dramatic
uh
heated up and reaction
happening in hong kong
for years so we wanted to do something
like that
and i haven't done this for for me
after 13 years of playing that man four
episodes
people forgot that i before it meant i
did
flashpoint and i did kill zone in those
films
those are the films that i'm actually
passionate about contemporary
that kind of style right so so we hit it
off and we wanted to do that
and then uh
and then so we did we just tackled it
and unfortunately
when we
after after we finished the film i went
to la and
attended the
mulan premiere and i it had three week
three months to edit the the director
cuts
so we we kind of uh
agreed on how we're gonna look things
he's gonna have his cut director cuts
he's gonna show me because i'm on the
producer as well right so he showed me
his cut and i'm gonna have my input
not only action but overall right so i
wanted to give him an input here and
maybe cut do my version of editing and
give it back to him and that's how we've
been working
uh for four or five months and then i
got a call from him and
one day
now all these times we were
communicating through
phone calls
like he would send his team he would
have it cut like he got a new cut after
say two weeks or three weeks he would
send over to my company
my film company in hong kong
and
with his
ad and
and it's the editor and we will edit
in my
in my uh
but then we can only we were exchanging
our thoughts through form and i was
finding very strange in the first four
four four five months then he called me
one day said you know
i'm sick
i caught it i said what what's going on
you know
and he got cancer he was diagnosed
cancer but he was very optimistic about
it right
and then we were very encouraging to all
his surrounding he was very positive he
said oh you know i'm doing everything
i'm doing this this therapist you know
this treatment and him there you know
but he did express
it was it was very painful and he
couldn't eat he lost a lot of weight i
mean it was so painful that that he had
never felt
in his in his entire life right
but we were very encouraging
uh
and not thinking that
he would survive right
and then uh
i think the month and a month before he
passed away we recall we had a call and
his condition was
going down and then
and then i continued to encourage him
and i
recommended another doctor to him and he
was one thing i remember mostly
that every time we talk
despite of
i mean basically man is dying
and he
only he talks about is how to make
raging fight better
you know what i'm saying like
exchange he was so he loved movie making
all we talked about was just how do you
make this cut or this scene and if we
change that shot to that shot if you
change that dialogue to that log you
know or take this scene from this sorry
constantly playing with that kind of
puzzle right putting the film together
so that's what i remember the most you
know he was very uh
the man loved movies more than his own
life i guess you know i mean
and then uh one day i got a call from my
uh
company's manager and she called me said
oh benny's in the icu
you should call him you know he's not
doing well he's reason
and
i hung up
and
news the news came up he passed away
just like that
that was a very a big a very big loss of
uh the whole entire
chinese film industry
i am i appreciate you sharing that story
and um i'm really sorry for your loss
and for his friends and family um
you know uh at least i i try to look at
you know a celebration of life and at
least he was doing something that he was
passionate about and he loved
you know uh steve uh
i i
i never stopped thinking about that
since he passed away
he passed away
without
a final cut
i
helped him to continue to uh
to finish cutting i keep cutting and
post production and me and another
there was a couple other guys like
working on
fixing the dialogue
we reached up the dialogues you know
trying to film and they read up these
dialogues just to make change a couple
of lines and then you know that's the
way we make films we change lines all
the time right so we just to make it
better
constantly making imperfections you know
we want to do bendy
justice and the film came out
with the number one whatever the reason
you know
the number one
print
but you know what he's not here to to
to cherish he's not here to take that
applause you know that
that praise you know he's not here he
doesn't know i mean
that is the
the tragic behind it when i look at this
is deeper than the film itself you know
it's the traffic
i never stopped thinking today every
every once uh once in a uh a while i
would think you know
we're focusing on this film we're still
tracking the box office but at the end
of the day doesn't matter because the
man who directed the film he's not here
he doesn't know
you know he's does it doesn't matter to
the family
you know obviously not right that's not
important what's important is like
life is short you know i mean this is
profound right this is like deep you
know this is something another object
another subject right
so
i don't i don't know you know sometimes
i have a mixed feeling of
what is what is this about you know like
on one hand
we we we we risk our life doing the
things that we love but on the other
hand life is so precious why are we
risking our life
you understand what i'm saying listen i
i have this i in the last few years i've
personally lost a number of people close
to me as i'm sure you have also lost
people close
and others the only thing that i've
learned as i've gotten older is to not
let things bother me the way they used
to and to cherish each day and to just
look if it makes you happy you know i
know you're risking your life for making
movies but it's clearly something you
love to do and you know what else you
know
there's no good answer you know what i
mean i'm not trying to get philosophical
but
it's there's there's no
you know what i mean not easy you're not
easy steve i mean i'm here i'm stuck in
berlin i'm just like
i'm making this film you know i wish
they can speed up the process as much as
i love chad and kim you know it's taking
too long you know it's like god damn you
know i miss my kids i miss my wife i
want to go home i wanna you know every
day while i'm sitting here
you know i mean they take care of they
could take good care of me but at the
same time look you know i want to be
with my family you know what they don't
like doing does your family never travel
with you when you're going to be on
location they travel it's just my kids
have school
oh yeah there's quarantines you know i
mean there's all kinds of situations
going on the world's not easy nowaday
you know
so but the fact that i'm
the the the simple fact that i'm like
half around the world you know
like thousand few thousand miles away
from my kids you know times are
different
when i call my kids they'd be asleep or
when they call me i'm like out of bed or
whatever you know i mean i don't
my kids grow up by the day
and
i miss my wife you know and i
i feel so guilty that she got to take
care of my film company because we want
a film company together right she got to
run everything in the company she got to
take care of the kids and she's going to
do everything i'm yes
it's not easy to make films right
but at the same time
this is the only thing i
i need to do is to do to make films well
my other half my missus gotta do a
million things you know so in a way i
feel really guilty i want to take part
for having that responsibility as
as a father
and a husband i think you're a very good
man and i think that uh it shows where
you the right priorities are i also
think though
that john wick is also such a huge thing
around the world it's such a popular
franchise that you know there's also the
element of you know being part of a film
like this also helps
you with other projects and maybe get
other things seen because you know more
people will learn who you are by being
part of john wick
so for my personal uh
interest and my personal achievement
you're absolutely right you know this is
something that uh
especially
knowing
luckily uh fortunately i'm working with
people like chad and kyung you know it's
it's that's a blessing right yes
but you know like i was saying you know
i'm a family man you know i want to be
with my mom my family i'm not trying to
be sentimental with you
in this particular sentimental moments
but i've been feeling that way
for the longest times
not saying i'm retiring soon but
maybe but it's all it's also because
you've been probably doing a lot of
night shoots and that plays with your it
messes with your head doing night shoots
i don't think is is what i've been doing
is what i've been thinking for before
this movie you know for i think it's
just many things that's happening in the
world you know uh
with
very close my benny pastor when my
father-in-law passed away uh last year
you know very dear he's like father to
me you know i mean so i have some
friends who also passed
passed away good friends and the past
few years you know
the and the older i get and i
i don't know why we're talking about
this we should be
talking about
movies promoting this making but i think
the truth is because both you and i in
the last few years have been going
through similar things in our own way
and i think we can both pick up on that
because i've lost the number of very
close people to me the last year
let's move past this talk and um
specifically i want to talk to you
because you are an expert
action director you have
crafted so many sequences and i'm very
curious how you
um get ready for a shoot in terms of
okay so say you're going to do raging
fire and you know you're going to be
filming let's say on march 1st this is
an arbitrary day
how early on are you breaking down the
action that you would like to have
happen in the movie are you pre-visiting
are you storyboarding can you sort of
take me through your process
i never did from day one
and i'm getting and i'm to a point where
it's
people have to understand that
i have different way of process art
especially when the physical art
uh choreography
i learned that very early on i learned
the way i function in my mind when i
work with you more pain as his action
director from
tiger cage from you know even
once upon a time with uh china when i
fought gently and you know i monkey and
all those when i was collaborating with
him and i was helping him
[Music]
obviously there's a certain function to
it there's a certain fundamental
mechanic behind it right because you got
to be technically you got to be
knowledgeable you got to be able to do
it you got to understand how it works
but at the end of the day it's about
expression i don't mean to sound
philosophical it's more expression how
do you express
the
ultimately
is the audience receiving you know
and from time time after time and after
time where when people look at my scene
and they respond to
with
with with with
uh this impressive uh response and
and i started to understand oh
it's all about getting
a reaction from the audience getting
that oh you know so basically it comes
down to a couple things it's deliveries
it's expression it's
uh like like singing a song
playing a piece of music how do i get
you emotionally involved and then
and in this particular
uh genre action film how do you get you
excited
how do you get you excited if you're
gonna if you're gonna throw if you're
gonna choreograph something like this
about two three four five six seven and
then you're gonna edit it one two three
four five six seven obviously you're not
gonna be excited right because we're
human we respond to
the signal of
you know turning it on right so for me
early on was tempo with
rhythm
was pacing
how did i choreograph where
there's an element of surprise that's
the highlight and then there's the end
that's the early
chain of thoughts
my early career when i
direct and choreograph
and later on
as i discovered about
you know i've been in business 40 years
for the first 20 years as an actor
truthfully i didn't know what the hell i
was doing as an actor
i don't know what the hell i was doing
as an actress honestly
because i was so focused on wanting to
be the best action guy
i mean frankly speaking in the beginning
i didn't know i i didn't i have no
intention of being an actor i was
discovered by your ping because he
thought i was he wanted to have a next
jackie chan he created jackie and he
made jackie chan famous by making
drunken master
uh and stake in the eagle shadow they
split up
jackie went to golden house so
truthfully european was not too happy so
he said i'm gonna make another jackie
chan let me look for another young guy
right he was scouting around for a few
years then somehow destiny called on me
and because my mom teaches martial arts
uh
she's a martial art maths one of the her
old students all the students when she
was teaching in hong kong before
we moved to lived in boston and opened
up a school in boston
one of the team one of his students
was
yuma king's
elder sister
so she told him that oh this kid i was 6
17 at the time you know this this this
kid he's really like you should check
check him out
so
i saw him at 18
got a little screen test showing what i
could do
and we made our first two movies
together that's how i was brought into
the industry i don't know i did no
proper training drama and
truthfully speaking a lot of those
old-time action directors you know they
weren't too
focused on the drama department if you
know what i'm saying right so i was not
taught properly and
guided properly and asked
how to be a good
uh actor and my personal journey and my
personal ambitions was i just want to be
the next bruce lee you know the best
action actor i could be and the best
action director because they go hand in
hand for you to become an action
best action guy obviously
beside your talent someone got to direct
you
and
and make you the best right so
you know what why don't i do it myself
so i started learning how to direct and
cuts you know and then i became a pretty
pretty uh uh influential direct uh
action director but then later on i
reached to a certain point where you
know
how much can i go and how far can i go
the industry already recognized me oh
donnie is the man he's the guy that
could
the best
actual guy right but then
what is the what do i want to do for
industry you know if you wanted to carry
that message if you wanted to pass the
knowledge of share your uh
creative uh
world right
you need more people to see that what
you're doing it's not just a niche of
people you're not making a movie to show
yourself so all this action direction
and choreography that i was doing
i was not i was not a popular style
in that regards i'm not jackie chan i'm
not jet li i couldn't let people see
more people to see what i could do so i
said you know what how can i make myself
to that level i got to be a better actor
right i got to be overactive with i
generate mass audience then i started
studying about oh you know then i
started to focus more of the athletes
department then then it gave me a man
then it came out the bodyguards and
disasters then then i slowly discovered
the love of
drama acting and the real and then and
switch kind of switch my path as an
action guy to a true
i call myself a true actor
you know i'm not a robert de niro but i
certainly know what is good acting
and in the past 10 years if you if you
realize a lot of these actions i don't
put focus on action anymore i could put
focus on the character because i
understand
if the audience are connected with
your the character that you created
and
better better yet if they love your
character they're gonna love everything
you do even if you your kicks is not as
sharp as what you used to do 10 years
ago that doesn't matter because people
are going to be on your side cheering
for you right so it's all about
character you build that character of
course the script the story has to give
you
the set you up where the audience kind
of stand for you and and you build that
up eight man was a very good example
when people emotionally attached to my
character when i fight like oh you know
we want master uh it man to win right so
yeah
so that's that's i don't think about
action anymore i think of i have my guys
to choreograph before i was very
specific
i'm sorry i kind of skipped so many uh
deep i gave you the specific answer to
your questions the specific answer was
back in the days
i was a perfectionist as far as
having the martial art technique down to
the teeth this martial art technique has
to be this way this block that would
have to shoot certain way that way
everything has to be the way i wanted it
exactly and i push for that
and later on
i just kind of to to and then now the
way i
direct or choreograph
i think of what would this character do
into in this storyline
would he encounter
uh
an example he walks in the room he has
to fight three guys
why
who those guys what's his emotion behind
it
then
when i nail those down i have a pretty
much id a good idea what i should do in
this environment
and then i have my guys to come up with
options one two three four five six
seven eight oh he could do this jump
over the table or kick this level up but
i'm naturally
the process of
this choreography change is always in my
head i've been doing it all my life so
it's naturally oh no he shouldn't care
he should kick
this right so
i'm focusing on
what the character would do but at the
same time
the technical choreography
it comes automatically
uh like a jazz i'm a musician i'm i'm
going into uh jamming with my band
i know how to jam and give me a
direction what are we playing oh let's
start playing let's jam on maybe go this
direction go that direction
sure i think that your performance in
raging fire is very good and especially
compared obviously to the beginning of
your career it is um
you know you've obviously progressed to
becoming a much better actor and it
shows in raging fire
well i hope that you can see uh uh have
a chance to see my upcoming project i
didn't really focus too much on i mean i
try to play a certain role with
limitations in enhanced understanding
the the nature of my role
uh finding that balance uh to play
a
a
uh flesh and and blood grounded cop like
a train a cops and that films that we
all watch like training days you know in
benzos and on the heeds and danelle
alpacino of course these are all great
actors that i
that motivates me but at the same time i
understand the elements of oh they want
to see donnie yen film they don't even
gotta be this so i gotta find that
balance to make him not all of a sudden
he becomes an in-man master and then at
the same time he's trying to be around
the person so i see the limitations
there right so that was
my
set of goal to achieve that right
i hope that you can see my other films
that i've completed and some uh it's a
thriller drama
that really really uh really i'm very
proud of
with with uh with the uh
the personalities you know i was looking
on your instagram last night when i was
prepping to talk to you and i saw you in
china in a province where you said it
was negative 20 degrees yeah which is
yeah yeah very cold yeah yeah that is a
defined moment for me as far as tackling
the road you know that is
that is a road to to break grounds for
my for my own
and
as an actor
i am curious what is the status of
sleeping dogs because you've talked
about that before you know based on the
video game do you think that's going to
happen
i'm still hopeful i mean
every day they tell me it's going to
happen
until i've been hearing from
my my i'm co-producing and collaborating
with neil morris and toby
with uh
with their company and
currently with talking with a couple of
big platforms so
and they tell me every single day it's
gonna happen so we'll see like i said i
believe in destiny so
if it's gonna happen
hopefully happen the first
half of next year can i ask you what is
it about that property um that says i
want to make this is it have you played
the game do you have you read a script
that you really honestly it was like
this
i did a
very i did a film that i'm not very
proud of
we all made some shitty films right i
made a film called uh
iceman
uh
a few years ago right one of the
producers came to me and said oh you
know donnie i saw this game this game is
perfect
a sony game
and they showed me the
the cover
and the guy actually looked a little
like what i did in my other films right
and i looked at some of the clips the
way they fight it and some of them move
my moves
and
and then i did some research and i found
some articles saying that the person
there's a group of people who create
this game created the world they want
their fans on mine and they
pretty much borrow some my actions and
even the image you know kind of and i
said oh that could be a fun vehicle
because
like i said
i was caught in the 12 13 years of the
eight man image that i want to go back
to
action contemporary action
and when i look at this material i said
wow
this could be a perfect action
like
contemporary action
world that i can i could do and it's
it's already have a
fan base right it it it's
uh internal internal affair and uh
uh you know flash point uh you know it
got all those elements kind of like
region five but even more edgier because
i'm playing undercover so i could do
so many things right it was very
uh at the time it was very uh
you know i was
really uh
attracted to it
and then the device went back and forth
from back and forth and and i tried to
inquire to sony's and and it costed too
much and they wanted too much money and
it went back and forth back for years
right
and then uh i got a call from uh
numerous two years ago they said they
got the properties then we started
talking and it's been a few years we've
been talking and talking and talking and
talking you know how slow it is in hong
kong we make like five movies already
right and we're still in discussion you
know i do own the rights of the
filmmaking so i want to let you know
that right i own the right
you know and i have full intention and
still wanted to do it and but how the
story is gonna go is it going to it's
it's going to based on the the game or
uh maybe some elements is
tracked
attracts uh from the the
from the games but most likely you're
probably gonna
make
up more of a modern like updated version
of sleeping dogs but i'm still in every
bit of in
ambitions to to honor to make that
because
i invested many years of
uh
kind of uh
into into this these projects and
now i'm not backing out now and they and
they and they promised me they tell me
every day is going to happen so
hopefully it will happen so because i
don't want to promise the fans and they
it's not going to happen but it looks
like it's going to happen is wait did
you say that you own the rights or neil
morris owns the rights the movie making
right uh the making that right
this this i owns this twit
okay got it i understand well the other
thing about the property is that and
maybe you agree with me and maybe you
don't i've always repeatedly said you
need a cool title and if sometimes these
movies come out and they have a terrible
title and it it just immediately for me
i'm like you could have done better
sleeping dogs is a good title
yeah sleeping that was good oh by the
way i think i own the uh i i'm sorry i
want to address that you know i think i
own the uh
uh the movie making uh uh
because there's a couple ownerships i
own the the title as well
oh so
yeah
you've gone full force you're really
you're serious you you want to make sure
well you know i mean
uh
yeah
okay
we're gonna do it all the way we're
gonna do it all the way you know have
you had any conversations with the game
company about possibly if this thing
gets off the ground you know making a
game based on the movie using the title
so like sleeping dogs colon
whatever it may be
i have a lot of different conversations
with
so many
so many people involved to a point where
let me just get this movie going first
because it's like
you know
uh
i don't want to lose my fire this raging
fire as where i still have a bit you
know we still have with sleeping dogs
now i think
i can i can really uh
i think it's going to be a really uh
fun
i can
vision
visualize the
the
the whole look of this film is going to
be a this could be something
very special but let me just focus on
getting this film made first you are
obviously in berlin filming wic i'm not
sure if you're a part of the photography
that's going to the other countries but
after you wrap on wic um do you already
know what you're doing over like you
know for the next year or are you sort
of like i'm going to go home and spend
time with my family and then i'll figure
things out i will spend of course i have
made to spend time with family but i i'm
not sure if i want to be away from my
family by feeling away from my family
more
anymore like no no
no farther than maybe
100 miles you know you know where i
could drive home i've got some i have
some a couple of projects lined up which
has been postponed
not postponed but kind of fixed my
schedule to fit john wick's in
so when i go back of course i'm going to
spend time you know christmas and
holidays i want to be with my kids and
my wife
i'm a workaholic you know when
i my project is always there and
there's there's a couple of big projects
next year
and like i said one of them is sleeping
dog
my last thing for you you have crafted a
number of action sequences which is the
one through your career that you still
have nightmares about which is the one
that really taxed you to pull off
oh man there's so many of them there's
so many of them i tell you well now i
still can't say every but nine and a
half out of ten
action movies that i've been
it is
i'm hard on myself
i always want to
take it to the next level or always
trying to push myself to what can i do
this time that
top the last one
not necessarily i succeeded because
that is a perspective from
audiences right to
to give answers
but at least i i give it a shot i give
it a try so when you have that kind of
expectation and kind of
hard on yourself
even the simplest simplest
uh
little fight scenes could be the hardest
because you're trying to be
perfect in every little detail you know
you know what i'm saying but
there's a couple of
unforgettable moments that i can share
with you that is crazy crazy
let me share with you
one
monkey king
people might not like they didn't like
the cgi in there but i tell you
when i did monkey king
it was the first time we used
the 3d camera it was the gigantic
monster we didn't know what to do with
it it was an experiment
for everybody
we had a team of prosthetic makeup
artists from hollywood
and they were trying different things on
my body
i remember the first
month of shooting
i need to put makeup on i have to sit on
a chair every day
for five and a half to six hours every
single day
so they give me this big giant chair
with music on i just sleep in my chair
putting all these pieces of hair i'm not
talking about the suits right on top of
a ball cap and this this piece of hair
and everything until my fully
like monkey
and then
obviously you can't eat you can't go to
bathroom you got a little zipper there
if you want to go through the big one
that's the problem right
and people can only drink water so you
can't really so
in the first two weeks i didn't know
what to do of my acting because it was
so hard to move my face i need to
experiment with my
my facial expression i have to really
enlarge them to make this facial
expression
so trying to get into character and and
i did a lot of my research i did some
research on how to play this monkey king
because monkey king was based on not
only from chinese mythologies and also
beijing opera so my take was
you know i'm gonna try to take it
a little bit of here and there right
based on some beijing opera some uh
and i literally went to the zoo and
study monkeys in cages and see how they
react you know
from uh
planet of the age
those movies
and some beijing opera and some just
you know the way i
tackle the character
and it was so tiring
both
the situation i was in
and moving as a monkey because
when you're moving everything when
you're moving the at the monkey king
everything has to be a twist there's a
difference between the way i played the
monkey king opposed to say steven chow
in monkey stephen charles played the
monkey in a more of a laid back kind of
cool like
like this but the way i portrayed the
monk kidding first of all that story is
the beginning of my game when he how he
grew up from a baby and he becomes a
monkey and i took that man a lot of but
an egg the banana like like a like what
a monkey did right there was a lot of
improvisation obviously on a set but
it's playing the monkey in the very
energetic and twisting and explosive way
bending my knees scroll crawling to john
vaughan you speaking of johnny five when
i walk to join the fight and acting with
him when he can be when it when he can
stay aligned with a
relaxed gesture
posing standing i have to twist it i
have to talk funny it was so tiring
everything
and
when you when the end of the day
you got to take out the outfits the
outfits
i probably lost
every day five pounds every day because
sweating inside
swear an hour and a half removing the
makeup
and
not only that i was the action director
we had we had a studio two studio studio
a for all the drivers and i have to go
to the great studio two right next door
like like literally right next to each
other
with my whole monkey suit
directing all the action scene
i'll be sitting there with my monkey
suit and with my microphone and with my
uh speaker microwave and cursing and
screaming and yelling and looking at
this stream this net and i remember
i was the actor and jonathan joe if i
was acting and aaron quark was acting
when john if i came i gotta skip all the
shots and you're going to shoot jonathan
first because his contract only
was out only on the set for six hours
and in two hours he would go around
shaking people's head so only have seven
call for four hours so i said oh brother
fat come on let's get you in this acting
getting in the shoot so i can only shoot
him for a couple hours so i gotta skip
all the shots with my monkey suits mom
shoot him
right then after him then aaron clark
comes in play the big bowl king shoot
him then at the end of the day i only
have two hours left shooting myself
shooting all the action then i have to
run back to the studio a to do drama so
it's the most stressful tiring
physically both mentally and physically
uh
task that was one
the other one quickly tell you
when i did bodyguards in assassins when
i fought kung li at the end you know i
have the ball caps on and to see some
prosthetic when i get beat up and i was
also the action director
that was the actual direction for the
end scenes where i
you know the actual director in hong
kong is basically basically a director
so i can take i and i shot the biggest
scene at the finale where there was 600
more than 600 extra
five cameras going where i have full
on prosthetic makeup
like
broken nose broken eyes and everything
right
it was
during summer july in the middle of july
with like
literally 30 something degrees right so
hot and humid and i was yelling and
screaming with the mic telling the the
the
the audience right out there come on
move this over 80 you know shoot this
and you know do all that while i'm
choreographing and with my stunt team do
this do this shoot this and
i'll tell you the hardest part wasn't
that the hardest part was there was
mosquitoes
thousands of mosquitoes biting the hell
out of you
i was shooting for freaking 24 hours
non-stop because i have to finish set
and i promise the director and producer
ben peter chan and teddy chan are gonna
finish that because at the end
we didn't have a lot of time left right
we have to rush finish the set finish
the film so there was a couple of guys
uh
uh peter chan would take the one cat uh
once one scene and you shoot the scenes
and then teddy sharon will shoot the
scenes and then uh uh
andrew lau who helped out and other
actresses that shoot that scene and i
took on the biggest fighting which
involved 600
uh extra so we were collaborating that
in that kind of setting right so the
mosquito was fighting through my outfit
i have like
hundreds of mosquito bites through my
outlet i couldn't i couldn't scratch it
i was like fighting it and
sweating and inside was heated and
and then i hurt my back and i couldn't
walk
and that's
that's just two of the very
i can tell you a thousand stories
this is just
maybe until next time this is the
just the
corner of uh
yeah i don't think one thing i'll tell
you all crazy crazy story crazy i was
gonna say i don't think people a lot of
people truly don't realize
what it takes to craft movies and action
and what really goes on behind the
scenes because i think a lot of people
from the outside it's very glamorous
you're a movie star you know you're you
know they just see the end product but
they don't realize that it's you know
six months or so you know they don't
really maybe understand
no it's this every shoot was a hard
shoot when i did it man the first one i
couldn't move full from my arms people
think oh danielle with the chain punch
with the wing chun and everything every
tick
if you poke me with a finger i would be
jumping with pain
it was so bad
both of my arms inside
had inflammation because i was punching
so many times every takes that in the
end of the day i couldn't lift my arms
and
when i was fighting i have to change my
choreography from like the choreography
was right side this side right then i
couldn't lift up my right hand
the actual director was sam hong so i
said uh uh uh
big brother samuel can i change
everything so i can't lift my arms can i
let me change all the movements to the
left hand so a lot of these
situations where people would never
guess a million years what happened
during this during those takes you know
i'm going to stop there because you've
given me so much time and i could keep
asking you questions and i know we could
talk the entire day but um but i'm going
to stop there and i'm just going to say
sincerely i really appreciate you
talking so much with me
thank you very much thank you for your
time as well